I mean people will say like oh you guys
were the fish of hip-hop The Grateful
Dead of hip-hop but it's it's like we
were dependable and responsible yeah so
our job was to stand by in the waiting
room it was good survival but it really
wasn't conducive for like having a a
steady relationship yeah they kids in
the factor now and you know so we around
like 2009 it was sort of like man we
wish like a a Selene Dion situation
would happen that a residency
a residency we just got to the mountain
toop of like making good money like we
finally made it and it's like do we just
turn our back on this and try something
unproven and we did it for us
um that was what we needed to actually
Bond and be friends again yeah there
there was a moment I know I'm a little
qucious give me a CO give me a safe for
like pineapple or something if I'm
talking too much
like I see you're turning maroon right
now I no I'm good that's his normal
color yeah that's just me when you see I
just those are called veins in my head
okay that's how white I am so there
there's a moment that happened around
two 2006 maybe three years before we did
Fallon and we're on tour of the chili
peppers and it's a European tour and
they're playing like soccer St I'm sorry
po post lasso football stadiums right
and you know it's like 80,000 to 120,000
a
night and every three to four songs
those guys get into sort of a football
magic circle
huddle and by the fourth time they do
this I'm thinking like oh they're going
to call an audible and change up the the
set list and then they go back to their
instruments and then I have the set list
in my hand I'm like wait they didn't
change anything they didn't change the
arrangement so I'm waiting like days
down the line like why do they keep keep
having these little meetings every like
five songs and nothing changes from what
I know the show to be it's like muscle
memory I see flea in the in the in
catering and I'm like dude what are you
guys talking about when you go into that
huddle and fle is like yo man it's like
I don't know man we're just we're so
full of gratitude like we're just four
guys that you know we met each other
when we were 13 and you know we're we're
in the da d d stadium with
120,000 people and we're just we're just
showing gratitude to each other like
guys we we really made it so this is 206
I'm not evolved yet as a human being so
I get on the tour bus and I'm like yo
man just like hippie
like oh we're so happy to be amongst you
know like I'm really just like ah being
dismissive of it like oh that's what
they're doing and my manager is like
yeah well makes sense like yeah I can
see that because they they like each
other that's cool I like yeah you know
so I go back and start playing
Place wait what do you mean they
actually like each other and he's like I
see that they actually I mean it's not
like a good fellow thing like what do
you mean I'm funny but it was sort of
like well what do you mean they actually
like each other like why' you say
actually he's like you see the chemistry
like they actually they with each
other I could see that and I was like as
opposed to what he's like come on man
and I'm like as opposed to what he's
like come on man don't make me spell it
out it's said what he said man y'all
don't with each other y'all just
show up ask y'all show up maybe y'all
come to soundcheck y'all show up at
Backstage y'all do it off memory you
know you you're the one to name the tour
buus is gyffin DF and slithering like
you it's like you got your own separat
tour buses y'all don't spend the night
each other's houses y'all ain't friends
y'all just business partners he's like
it's cool like keep the peace that's
funny that you didn't know you didn't
know well I thought look we been by that
point we had known like we met in ' 87
and it's now 2007 like it's 20 years
later like what do you mean we're not
friends and then I realized oh
we're really not friends like we're just
like nine strangers that just play the
same songs every night and that's it and
so what wound up happened at Fallon is
Jimmy has a way of disarming you mhm and
I'll say at least for the first six
years like we were Perpetual we were 13y
olds we were 13 year olds in adults
bodies doing we we could do silly things
and not feel like you know like oh we're
going to lose our street Craig because
we're
doing silly there there's a moment
where when jimmmy officially pitched us
and we're doing like some spring fing at
at UCLA or something and I'm I mean I'm
quasi spokesperson for the group and so
I had to do an interview like with the
college paper or something so I went in
trailer did my interview came back 20
minutes later and we're on UCLA's uh
football field and Jimmy all right this
is gonna be my worst reference and I'm
in my head like please don't say this
reference can we just take a guess
around the table what this is going to
be you go first uh wait I I'll give you
a hint no
I I'll give you a hint will am oh Zapped
or godamn you're good Zapped this is why
I messed them in yeah zaap the movie
where Scott beo can make people's bras
fly off it's either out Charles in
charger Bible man how do well no where
he first started which was 8 8 is okay
so Jimmy somehow has talk The Roots into
doing an uh an eight-man uh human period
pyramid a
period a human period I don't know as
much
about anyone want to weigh in oh oh God
that we stick with pyramid I have to
okay yeah so you know they're doing a
human pyramid and it it wouldn't have
phased me more but Tariq and I are such
Polar Opposites of each other by this
point Tariq is one of those like you
know
$5,000 uh Japanese denim wearing fanas
yeah uh of which I was like yo he's
really on the bottom row on his KNE like
he's ruining his his denim he would
never do this he's one of those Jesus
Christ like not spot nor wrinkle
meanwhile I will go to the White House
with like uh mustard stains on on my on
my tucks and I looked at my manager and
I was just
like we're not we're not getting rid of
this guy anytime soon right
and my manager like we're stuck with him
like literally Jimmy would
not let up until we we committed to him
and he just TI like just did it and so
what I'll say is now the amount
of uh being in the gym on that show has
actually made us friend again yeah and
so now I I feel like even though this is
our 30th year as a band I really feel
like it's like our seventh
year